Hôm cao của sẽ nông như ở bà môi trường xưa ra cho biết là từ ngày 16 cho đến ngày 20 hình thân mấy,
trên địa bàn tỉnh đã chỉ hoàn gồm của bảo số một.
Mọi người sau bảo kết hợp giản nắp thích và bộ vổ thủ gió trên cao.
Gây ra ma đật mưa lớn, nhưng đôi khi nhận lượng mưa trên hai trạm bií li mặt, trên hai bí thủ gió.
Dẫn đến lụ quét, nập ủng và sạch lợp đất tại nhiều đefương.
Trong đó, sẽ ngọt chiến là đefương chiếu thị thải nặng đến nhất,
tiếp đến là các sả mừng là vượn bú, chiân lào, mừng trên, mừng hương, chiân hoa, tà suồ và sĩnh vang.
Theo tổng kê, mưa lụ làm hình muốn chăm mù nhà bị anh hợp.
Trong đó thì có mùi hai nhà bị thị thải hòn tuàn, mùi chăm thà mi ba nhà bị thị thải nặng.
Mùi chăm thà mi lâm nhà phải dây phần cấp.
Mọi gia tị muốn chăm học, một cơ giợi tế một công trình bàn hoa,
muốn mời công trình từ lợp và mởi công trình cấp rất sinh hoa, mị thư học.
Trong là ý bực sản xuất, tiến thải đã làm thiệt thải gần thải chăm sau mùi hết tà lua,
hơi mỗi bụn hết tà, kê hằng nắm và kê lâu nắm.
Như già xuất già còn bị chết, gần thải mùi hết tà nuôi trong thị sản biển vợ.
Mời lụ cũng gây nhiều sự cố vẻ thống biệt thông, trong khi hẳng nghiệm giảm sắp lợi,
xuất hiện ở trên cấp tuync quốc lộ, tịch lộ và đường giáu thông đồng thôn.
Lên này thì cấp tuync quốc lộ và đường tỉnh đã được thông xa xe là.
Theo sở nụng nghiệm ở bà mỗi trường xin ra thì đây là được tiến thải dịch biến đặc biệt phút tà,
khi cấp lợi lời lớn sẽ ra liên tiếp trong thế giản gắn, khiến nhiều khu vực chiêu kìm khắc phục sông,
đã a chíu tắc lộng khu vực lợi mơ sông, sẽ ra tình trạng lú trong lũ.
Thế giá tớ thì tiến tiếp tục, theo gió chặt chèa dịnh miếng vừa lũ,
giữ chiêu chực bán hàng vitor trên hàng vitor gió.
Già xuất các khu vực có người cơ sảy ra lú quốc, sạch lợi để chủ động sơ tạng đôi và tài xa khi cạnh thiệt.